the cost of living crisis continues to
bite and this is data from the UK's
largest survey of businesses a British
Chamber of Commerce looking back over
the past quarter now if we take a look
at domestic sales you can see here this
red bar at the bottom this is the number
of businesses who say that their sales
have decreased in the past quarter has
gone up to nearly a quarter as you can
see it's been rising fairly steadily
over the past two years but in
particular if you look up at that blue
bar that's the number of businesses who
show that their sales have increased and
that's dropped quite substantially to
just a third compared to 41 in the last
quarter now if we look ahead to how
businesses are feeling about their
profitability over the next year this is
also a fairly dismal picture so 39 of
businesses now say that they believe
their profits are going to go down next
year compared to around a third who
believe they'll go up and so if you look
at this aggregate data here curve it's
going down it's now going into the
negative and as you can see it's really
nose diving quite dramatically heading
down on its way not as bad as we saw in
the worst of the covid lockdown in 2020
and also of course if you look back to
2008 we've still got some way to go
before we get that serious but obviously
not a good picture about how positive
businesses are feeling there now if we
also take another look at the percentage
of firms who say they're likely to have
to increase their prices over the next
year of course this is a real indicator
of how inflation is going to continue to
increase for some time yet we can see
that although it's not quite as high as
the last quarter it's only notched down
a very little bit so prices set to go up
now important it's important to say that
this survey was done before the
government announced their package of
support for businesses in terms of
energy help and the mini budget of
course but yesterday we had more gloomy
news from the National Grid projecting
the possibility unlikely but a
possibility that we might have to see
three hourly blackouts to deal with
problems with energy Supply which of
course is an absolute blow to the heart
of many businesses Downing Street of
being adamant previously that they're
not going to introduce rationing or tell
people to cut their consumption well
yesterday that's something that Liz
truss wouldn't repeat and there are
calls by many experts for the government
to be doing more to make people use less